[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute gibt es richtig leckere Cupcakes
mal wieder die hatte ich mal für meine
Freundin gemacht weil meine Freundin
kokosfan ist die Leila und die habe ich
mit zu ihr genommen und weil sie Besuch
erwartet hat habe ich es als Mini
Cupcakes gemacht und dachte ich mir so
fürs Video mache ich jetzt auch Mini
Cupcakes denn so kann man sie wirklich
nicht in einem hab's ich finde schon man
muss Cupcakes abbeißen so wie bei
Plätzchen und bei Cookies eine
abweispflicht gibt es da bei mir weil
ich will dass Menschen die meine Sachen
essen auch sehen dass ich eine Füllung
drin habe und das sieht man nur wenn man
abbeißt deswegen gibt es eine
abweispflicht aber auf zwei Hubs könnte
sie gerne vernaschen jedenfalls habe ich
hier einen richtig schönen leckeren
saftigen kokosmuffin in der Mitte eine
himbeerfüllung eine leckere Vanillecreme
oben drauf und das ganze getoppt und
dekoriert mit Raffaello weiß
geschmacklich sehr gut passt und einfach
hübsch ausschaut ich finde die sehen aus
wie so kleine Kunstwerke ja es ist Kunst
und es kann weg denn es kann in den
Bauch
ebenfalls starten wir direkt mit dem
Teig das ist ein ganz schneller Teig All
in One Rührteig Zutaten die jeder zu
Hause hat wahrscheinlich und vor allem
die sehen zwar so ein bisschen aufwendig
aus sind sie aber gar nicht und so wenn
ich sie mir so angucke finde ich passen
sie auch echt gut auf so eine
Hochzeitstafel so ein Buffet so ein
sweet table könnt mal richtig schön
machen ein bisschen Glitzer noch drüber
und fertig jedenfalls gibt es jetzt hier
erstmal die Zutaten für den Rührteig
dafür verwende ich 150 Gramm Zucker
etwas Salz 180 Gramm Mehl plus
Backpulver oder nehmt mein backmehl 80
Gramm Kokosflocken Vanilleextrakt zwei
Eier und jeweils 150 Gramm
Sonnenblumenöl und Buttermilch
zuerst verrührt ihr jetzt die trockenen
Zutaten in eure Rührschüssel und ihr
wisst ich liebe Muffins ich liebe
Cupcakes denn ihr braucht keine
Küchenmaschine kein Handrührgerät geht
alles so schnell und immer wenn ich Lust
auf eine Torte habe aber keine Zeit auf
eine Torte um die zu backen dann mache
ich Cupcakes ich habe natürlich eine
Sache vergessen beim Moderieren nämlich
dass ich die Kokosraspeln noch etwas
zerkleinern will
und das geht am besten
wenn ihr ein bisschen Mehl mit
reinmischt
einfach Mehl dazu in so ein Mixer und
dann kann man sich schön fein malen
entweder könnte das hier machen oder
doch in der Küchenmaschine oder in der
Mixer
ihr könnt aber auch im Groben lassen ich
will halt einfach nur dass du so ein
bisschen feiner sind
[Musik]
und dann gerne die flüssigen Zutaten mit
rein statt Buttermilch könnt ihr auch
normale Milch nehmen gibt dann
vielleicht einen Schluck Zitronensaft
dazu das Sonnenblumenöl mit rein und da
ist immer wichtig nicht dieses Bio
Sonnenblumenöl was kaltgepresst ist denn
das hat so ein ziemlich starken
Eigengeschmack sondern wirklich ganz
herkömmliche Sonnenblumenöl was man eben
auch zum Frittieren nehmen kann das ist
hier perfekt weil es geschmacksneutral
ist
Vanilleextrakt noch rein den Ofen habe
ich schon vorgeheizt auf 200 Grad
und jetzt einfach nur kurz verrühren bis
sich alles verbunden hat
[Musik]
falls ihr jetzt Mini Cupcakes backen
wollt dann werden es 48 wenn ihr ganz
normale Cupcakes backen wollt sind 12
also entweder macht ihr die Miniform
habe zwei Bleche oder eben eine ganz
normale Muffinform dann sind 12 Stück
also nicht zwölf Bleche sondern
einmachen Blech ich gebe hier die
Papierförmchen rein
es geht immer am besten guck mal wenn
ihr diese runter streift dann verformen
sie sich nicht
und dann füllt ihr die Muffinförmchen
ganz gleichmäßig mit dem Teig und bei
den kleinen nehme ich immer den kleinen
Eisportionierer und bei den normalen
Muffins immer den großen Eisportionierer
da ist dann immer die perfekte Menge
drin und wenn ihr zwei Bleche backt dann
könnt ihr auch bei Heißluft Backen
ansonsten auch gerne bei Ober-Unterhitze
eine eisportion voll
ich mache jetzt hier 24 Cupcakes und aus
dem Rest mache ich jetzt also ihr könnt
noch mal 24 Cupcakes machen oder einfach
Gugelhupf und ich glaube ich will heute
noch ein paar Clubs deswegen das Blech
schön einfetten
und dann den Rest hier drin backen
dann gibt es noch Minigolf und da habe
ich das Blech nämlich auch extra so das
eine Eis Portion voll perfekt ausreicht
wenn ihr zwei Bleche gleichzeitig backt
dann nehmt ihr am besten immer die
Einschubleiste 1 und die drei
das ist nämlich genug Platz dazwischen
damit die Hitze bei der Heißluft schön
zerkulieren kann
ich drehe immer das Backblech dann um
dann habe ich die gerade Fläche
ist hier einfach rein
die Cupcakes sind jetzt fertig und auch
bereits abgekühlt jetzt kann ich hier
die Creme zubereiten dafür verwende ich
250 Gramm Quark 40 Gramm Puderzucker
Vanilleextrakt 200 g Sahne und
viereinhalb Teelöffel Sahne Part es gibt
ihr erst einmal den Quark in die
Rührschüssel und meine Art dazubereitung
von Cremes weil ich glaube ich immer so
ein bisschen ab bei anderen wie von
anderen denn ich verrühre immer zuerst
Quark Puderzucker und Vanilleextrakt und
schlage die Sahne nicht extra steif habe
ich früher als Tini auch gemacht aber
irgendwann habe ich mir gedacht nö
braucht man gar nicht denn wenn man San
apart benutzt San apart macht ja auch
Cremes also andere Cremes steif außer
nur Sahne wie zum Beispiel Quark oder
ist auch gut wenn Mascarpone oder eben
auch Schmand und andere Milchprodukte
deswegen kann ich das hier so verrühren
Sahne dazu gießen und pro 100 Milliliter
Flüssigkeit also Schmand Sahne quark was
auch immer gebt ihr einen Teelöffel
davon
so sieht die Creme jetzt perfekt aus die
stelle ich kurz in den Kühlschrank da
kann sie noch ein bisschen anziehen und
ich kann dann in der Zwischenzeit schon
mal die Cupcakes füllen und zwar nehmt
ihr jetzt dafür entweder eine
Himbeermarmelade ohne Stückchen am
besten fein passiert oder ihr könnt auch
gerne selbst Himbeeren pürieren also
einkochen und pürieren so habe ich es
auch gemacht ich habe immer Himbeerpüree
auch auf Vorrat das heißt ich nehme
tiefgefrorene Himbeeren Pack nur ein
bisschen Zucker mit dazu kocht das ganze
schön auf zu einem Püree und streiche
dann durch den Sieb aber ihr könnt wie
gesagt auch hier bei Marmelade nehmen
ich habe ich jetzt die Cupcakes dann
hier einen Spritzbeutel mit der
fülltülle hier vorne
stellt jetzt hier kurz den
spritzbeutelständer und da packe ich
jetzt mein Himbeerpüree rein
damit fülle ich jetzt die Cupcakes so
habe ich einfach gleich so einen richtig
schönen fruchtigen Geschmack mit dabei
ganz so finde ich die Cupcakes einfach
perfekt denn man hat den schönen
Kokosnuss Geschmack hier die
Fruchtfüllung ohne Zucker das dann so
ein bisschen säuerlich dann die Creme
drauf perfekt also hier einfach leicht
einstechen so ein bisschen drücken das
sieht man tatsächlich nicht also wie
viel man da jetzt rein macht aber das so
ein bisschen so eine gespürsache
jetzt sind sie schon gefüllt ich habe
jetzt eine Lochtülle und die ist für die
Creme das heißt die Creme kommt jetzt
hier in den Spritzbeutel
ihr könnt natürlich auch wenn ihr wollt
eine sternentülle nehmen aber ich will
dass die jetzt so ein bisschen moderner
und minimalistischer aussehen und jetzt
haltet ihr den Spritzbeutel so also
richtig schön senkrecht oben zugedreht
und dann kommt dann schöner großer
Tupfen drauf
habe ich hier so ein paar
gefriergetrocknete Himbeeren die haben
den Vorteil die sind schön trocken und
ich kann sie pulverisieren oder sogar
mit so einem Haarsieb so ganz fein
drüber reiben ja so ist die perfekte
Technik so einmal so durchstreichen
und jetzt könnte sie entweder so lassen
oder nehmt noch eine Raffaello Kugel und
halbiert die die passt einfach
geschmacklich auch perfekt dazu optisch
auch nur beim halbieren immer ein
bisschen aufpassen hat nicht
funktioniert
vielleicht nehme ich ein glattes Messer
und dann setze ich die drauf und dann
sind die Cupcakes auch schon fertig
richtig gut und richtig schnell ach ich
finde die eigentlich auch so
aufgebrochen gar nicht schlecht
ja
[Musik]
perfekt so sind die Cupcakes fertig und
ich stelle sie kurz in den Kühlschrank
Räume hier auf und dann werden sie
gleich probiert
die sind so schön
oh nein da ist voll wie immer
Kühlschrank
ich stehe einfach hier
kühlt auch
ich glaube ich probiere heute einfach
selber
ich hatte nämlich so Lust auf diese
Cupcakes
zack
so und dann so
guck mal
hübsch
jedenfalls bin ich ganz froh dass ich
mehrere Bleche davon gebacken habe und
wir davon jetzt noch einige im
Kühlschrank haben die lassen sich jetzt
ganz gut bis morgen Lagern allerdings
würde ich euch einen Tipp geben bereitet
gerne den Cupcake vor die Creme
obendrauf aber die Himbeeren also die
gefriergetrockneten und die Raffaellos
würde ich nur frisch drauf geben damit
sie einfach nicht mit Feuchtigkeit in
Berührung kommen jetzt sieht man schon
so ein bisschen die haben so ein
bisschen Feuchtigkeit aufgezogen finde
ich nicht schlimm aber gerade die
Raffaellos schmecken frisch halt am
besten und über Nacht wenn die da so im
Kühlschrank sind specken sind immer so
ganz gut deswegen lieber ganz frisch
also das Rezept findet ihr auf
sallys-blog.de in meiner App und ich
hoffe euch gefällt diese Kombination aus
Himbeer und Kokos probiert's gerne mal
aus ich finde Rafael aus passen da
perfekt dazu aber ihr könnt mir auch
gerne mal euer Feedback schreiben und
dann würde ich sagen starten wir doch
ganz bald mit der Weihnachtsbäckerei
also falls ihr Wünsche habt für die
Weihnachtsbäckerei dann schreibt es mir
gerne in die Kommentare ich freue mich
schon drauf bis zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]